John is with us in San Diego hey John
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thanks
for taking my call sure how can I help
my question is about um well me and my
wife we're currently on baby step 2 um
we should be done paying off our debt
our goal is by the end of this year we
should be debt-free but my actual
question is um for my $1,000 emergency
fund because um I know that $1,000 will
you know cover my any small emergency
stuff like that but at the same time I
always get nervous and what if something
happens in something a major emergency
that's gonna cost more than $1,000 you
know that will require that amount and
so my question is would you recommend or
would would you recommend me to at least
beef up my $1,000 to like 1,500 or 2,000
or stick to the $1,000 um and how much
did you have in savings before you start
all this I'm trying to say it again
sorry how much did you have in savings
before you started all this I think it
was well we started I totally forgot but
I know we I saved up close to a thousand
so you a man you've never had more than
a thousand I've never had well actually
be I think I had one but I purchased it
to the UM I remember I had almost two
thousand dollars for when we purchased
our water here and it worked and so I
used that amount and so we're down to
one thousand dollars okay so you've
never had more than three thousand
dollars in your life never never okay
all right and and what's your household
income sir between me and my wife take
close to probably like fifty five
thousand a year good good for you okay
cool all right and and you said you
would be debt-free not counting
your house by the end of the year not
planning to house yes are I think our
total debt right now is close to a
little over six thousand mm-hmm
okay you should be debt free before then
then okay all right you need tighten
this budget up and get out here's the
thing here's the thing okay the
difference in a thousand and 1500 with
all the different things that can happen
to us really isn't spit and so if you
cheat on the baby steps and make it
1,500 does it does it end the world no
but it really doesn't help you that much
I mean because I mean the chances of you
having a $3,000 event is still just as
high and 1,500 doesn't help with that
and so what I would do if I were in your
shoes is I would stick with the thousand
with the idea that it's very temporary
we're only six thousand dollars away
from starting to raise this account and
I would use a little bit of the fear
that you have as my motivator for
cutting really really deep and for being
on a budget a written plan on my every
dollar app with my wife and we're going
to be very very very detailed here
because here's the thing if you can find
a thousand dollars a month out of your
fifty five thousand you'll have that
other debt paid off in six months and a
month later you'd have two thousand in
your savings in a month later you'd have
three thousand your savings in a month
later you'd have four thousand in your
savings and by the end of the year you
could have six thousand seven thousand
dollars saved and be debt-free if you
did this at a at a rate for starting
today of a thousand dollars a month and
a thousand dollars a month is doable on
fifty five and a part-time job and a
garage sale and selling some stuff
looking around there what else we can do
might make all this happen even faster
and so the good news is you don't have a
lot of debt so there's not a lot
standing between you and actually
starting to build a real emergency fund
because the thousand dollars I agree
with you it's not enough it's not enough
it's just it's almost as much as you've
ever had though and so I want to get you
in a position that for the first time in
your life you're sitting on ten thousand
dollars as your emergency fund and no
payments in the world but your house
payment
that's where I want you to go and I
really think you're not that far from
that
so let's lean in and let's do that